hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game that took place in an
incredible match it happened yesterday
uh in round five of the ftx crypto cup
uh it is a uh basically game two of the
match youngshish of duda versus magnus
carlsen this is the rapid portion uh but
as you guys know the four games of rapid
uh well we're going to discuss what
happened in the match before we check
out the after we check out the game
because it's um a really spectacular one
so here and sorry about this we just
have to shift the players uh magnus lost
the first game we've seen that one if
you haven't seen it do check it out it's
my previous video uh duda played a
brilliant brilliant end game and
completely outplayed magnus after magnus
made a tiny tiny mistake
and it was enough for do that to claim
the whole game and now this is the
second game magnus has the white pieces
and he will of course try to
retaliate and he most certainly does try
so let's check it out magnus plays pawn
to e4 we have e5 knight to f3 knight to
c6 and bishop to b5 the ruy lopez is on
the board knight to f6 and now pawn to
d3 we have bishop to c5
a very very modern way of of challenging
uh white's attempt at uh
countering the berlin defense and not
bishop captures on c6 we have d captures
and knight b to d2 so this is all very
standard of course the e5 phone cannot
be captured because queen to d4 attacks
the knight and threatens checkmate so uh
this is an in between move and now of
course black has to do something about
the e pawn so knight to d7 defends the
pawn we always uh say that there are
various ways that you can defend the
pawn such as moving the bishop moving
the knight and so on uh and now knight
to f1 by magnus with castles by duda and
now magnus goes pawn to g4 he lost the
first game now he needs to bounce back
and he wants to start pushing those
pawns and attack dude as king side
and there is a game where bishop the b
for check was played it was played in
the game nisi piano versus bin rifalho
from 2017 the game ended in a draw uh
but here we have rook to e8 by duda and
it is now as of move 8 that we have a
completely new game so let's see how
magnus continues we have knights to e3
the knight now has access to f5 so that
could be very dangerous uh and duda says
pawn to a5 he says uh if this was good
everyone would play this i'm not worried
about your pawn pushing on the king side
i'm just going to play on the queen side
stop your from playing a b4 so this is
obviously good for me so rook to g1
magnus sticks to his plans and now
knight to f8 we have pawn to h4 and duda
still not impressed just plays pawn to
a4 we have knights to f5 by magnus and
now pawn to b5 duda completely ignores
him plays on the queen side we have
bishop to g5 attacking the queen and now
point to f6 chasing the bishop back with
bishop back to d2 and now king to h8 so
how do you continue here with magnus
there are various ways that you can play
this you could play a king to f1 as you
are probably not castling this game you
could play a three stop further
expansion on the queen side you could
start with h5
but magnus actually decided to play pawn
to g5 and this is the move that duda
said when he saw it he was
incredibly impressed not by how good it
is but how magnus actually played it so
here duda starts capturing bishop
captures on f5 e captures on f5 and now
pawn to e4 uh that's why we said that
the king would be better placed on f1
now if the position opens up could get
very ugly d captures an e4 rook captures
on e4 king to f1 and now queen to d5 by
duda preparing to bring the other rook
into the game uh we have g captures on
f6 g captures and bishop to c3 and it
seems like magnus is definitely on to
something
controlling this diagonal controlling
the g file with the rook offering a
queen trade if you do the trades then
magnus gets the rook into the game but
uh dude of course uh goes for queen
captures on f5 it is the best move and
the only way to push for the win with
black so here rook g5 a very nice rook
lived by magnus of course the rook
cannot be captured the pawn is pinned
but now queen to h3 with check again the
only way to play for the win but to do
that spots it very quickly king the g1
and not rook the g4 with check
eliminating one of magnus's attackers
rook captures on g4 queen captures on g4
and now king to h1 as the king is in
check and now knight to d7 a beautiful
beautiful move uh
that prepares to bring the rook into the
game but also uh bishop the d6 will be a
very very nasty move for magnus to
handle so here knight the h2 attacks the
queen also um
offers a queen trade
and now uh just queen captures on h4 now
grabbing a pawn but this game really
isn't about uh counting pawns now bishop
to d6 wants this lands uh it is just
game over and this even comes with a
sacrifice of a piece but you know that
once this knight is captured and bishop
to d6 lands uh you are not defending
this position so queen captures on d7 is
the only move you could also go for
queen to g4 offer a queen trade but
after captures and captures it's really
not
all that great magnus is down to pawns
and it's just a better position for
black so instead after queen captures an
h4 magnus has to go for queen captures
on d7 and now just bishop to d6
absolutely beautifully played by duda
king to g2 you have to start running
away with your king queen captures an h2
king to f1 and now queen to h1 with
check we have king to e2 hoping that
duda captures the rook then we can play
bishop captures and queen the g7
checkmate but of course duda will not do
that so here queen to e4 check king to
f1 and now queen to c4 with check king
to e1 we have rook to f8 now seems like
a passive move but it is necessary to
defend this spawn and now bishop defends
rook rook defense pawn this pawn is
defended by the bishop bishop defends
the pawn everything is defended there is
no way for magnus to break through in
this position but he can finally get his
rook into the game rook to d1 and it
seems that if he can get king to d to
king c1 in
in there uh he's back in the game but
duda just plays queen to e4 with check
and now the sad reality is that if king
to d2 bishop to f4 is checkmate
that's the problem for magnus so he has
to go back with the king or rather to
the open board king to f1 and now queen
to h1 with check king to e2 and here
another beautiful move by duda just
queen the h5 with check and it was in
this position unmoved 34 that magnus
carlson resigned the game as there is
nothing more uh to be done here the
queen here is absolutely beautifully
placed the point is that if the king
moves to away from the rook you just
captured the rook with the check if you
remain on e1 we can just play rook t8
with czech we can ensure that king d1
rook 28 with check and now there really
aren't any moves for example king d2
bishop def or another
mating maneuver king to d3 now queen to
e2 with czech king d4 and queen to c4
will be a beautiful checkmate uh with
the king in the center of the board so
after queen to h5 check there are no
moves and of course it was in this
position that magnus resigned the game
if you try f3 yes it's possible but
still rook to e8 again just ends the
game for example king to f2 now we can
even play queen to h2 uh with czech king
to f1 queen to e2 with czech king the g1
now this wonderful bishop to hd with
check king the h1 queen captures on f3
with czech sacrificing the bishop for
checkmate king captures rook to e to
check king to g1 and now queen the g1
will be checkmate so
beautiful beautiful stuff of course
magnus sees all of this and he was uh
forced to resign the game here so this
is the second game of the rapids duda
won the first game brilliantly he won
the second game with the black pieces
brilliantly so is there any chance for
magnus carlsen to bounce back well
believe it or not magnus actually won
the next two rapid games on demand and
he was able to force tie breaks which uh
i mean which was just incredible and he
didn't go wild or anything he just
played completely calm chess um
waited for dude's mistakes he he he
pushed for a long end game and in the
end he outplayed duda he himself said
that he played terribly and uh well it
is definitely not something to be proud
of but duda
at some point played even worse than
that and then he was able to win he he
was able to force uh tie breaks and then
duda uh claimed the first win in the
blitz tie breaks and again magnus needed
to win on demand to force armageddon and
this is the position from the final
blitz game
and it's really really a beautiful one
here magnus played the d4 and i'm just
going to show you what happened here
because it's absolutely uh spectacular
here duda played ponte e6 now
threatening pawn captures on f7 which
would win the game so f6 chasing away
the knight and inviting the knight to f7
knight to f7 was played let me just
switch this so you guys um i have a
better idea of who's playing who do that
has the white pieces here so king to g7
and now queen to d2 a beautiful square
for the queen because now if carlson's
queen ever moves you can play pawn to f5
and go for this queen to h6 checkmate so
d3 by magnus uh attacking the rook
preparing c4 and c3 uh rook eat the e1
and now pawn to c4 and now
this c4 push came a bit too soon but
this is blitz so of course duda uh
that doesn't have all the time in the
world the uh make use of it but he finds
the absolute best continuation knight to
d4 attacks the queen which forces the
queen from f5 which means you can push
f5 and then go for this queen to h6
checkmate so queen d5 by magnus pawn the
f5 threatening queen h6 king jade and
queen to h8 checkmate now rook to h8
magnus has to stop this and offer a rook
but the duda is not interested in
grabbing the rook he prefers to have a
knight on f7 and who wouldn't this is uh
this is truly a
a a monster knight so queen to f4 by
duda and now knight to c6 by magnus we
have knight to b5 and now queen captures
on f5 magnus now
offers a queen trade goes uh for the end
game because he does have these two
pawns dude happily accepts queen capture
spawn captures knight captures on h8 now
he says all right we are in the endgame
i will grab the material rook captures
on h8 and now rook captures on f5 by
duda and magnus goes rook to d8 here the
incredible thing is that just d2 is
winning for magnus but it's blitz a very
little time on the clock point is that
after rook to d1 the move that um well
magnus obviously missed is bishop to b4
this wins the c3 square and now c3 is
coming there's no stopping this whatever
you play it doesn't really matter for
example g2 just c3 and if c2 lands this
game over so you're gonna have to give
up your knight and now of course magnus
is up too much material he will win this
game easily so after rook captures an f5
magnus played rook to d at first he
prepares the pushing of the d-pawn and
now rook to b1 by duda and now d2 still
completely winning magnus goes for king
to g6 first and now rook to f4 now the
position is uh well uh
better for magnus but not very very
clear because here if you push d2 then
just knight to c3 and if bishop to b4
which worked in all of those previous
moves uh lines just pawn to e7 and now
you don't have a move if the the rook
moves away from the d file you no longer
control d1 also rook captures and c4
will defend the knight so that's out of
the question you're just going to have
to play bishop captures on e7 and then
we uh rook captures on c4 comes and
that's it
you can no longer push for advantage
here so instead knight to e5 was played
but now luda plays knight to c3 we have
pawn to d2 finally magnus plays it but
now
it is not enough rook captures on b7
saying okay you promote this pawn to a
queen you're going to win my knight but
i'm going to win your bishop on e7 so
here rook to d3 by magnus going after
the knight on c3 now the beautiful
knights to d1 by duda we have pawn to c3
and now rook to c7 do that not allowing
magnus to push this pawn to c2 bishop to
b4
uh set up perfectly like in the lines
that we've shown only the differences
here the uh position is now completely
lost for magnus uh rook captures on b4
that's the problem yes you've seen it
correctly magnus played bishop to b4 and
he completely blunders a bishop a little
time on the clock the nerves were
well already at the edge and they
it was it was only a matter of time
before one of them
messes up like this magnus was the one
to mess up first and of course now the
position is completely winning for duda
knight to f3 check was played king to h1
and he was in this position that magnus
cause and resigned the game and with the
match uh there's or uh maybe a few more
moves were played yeah magnus played
knight stay e1 then pawn to e7 by duda
king to f7 and now rook to b8 uh i
believe or maybe no let me just check
uh i don't want to trick you guys but i
i'm pretty sure that the game ended with
this king to h1 yeah the game ended with
the with the move king to h1 uh but uh
the the the reason it ended is that it's
completely winning for example knight's
d1 e7 now preparing the queening of the
pawn and now there's no defense against
this if king to f7 just rogue b8 uh and
now of course this will be uh just game
over c2 and we're gonna play e8 queen
and this is now checkmate uh so yeah
sorry about that i forgot uh that it
actually ended with um uh with the
moving of the king on h1 uh with a
brilliant brilliant display by duda he
could have uh
taken the match much much sooner but uh
magnus was able to get to his head a
little bit but duda once again shows why
he is known or referred to as the magnus
kryptonite uh as he he he has a tendency
of you know ruining carlson's winning
streaks
uh and also uh yeah here are the
standings after uh
after day five magnus is still leading
with 13 points as prague lost uh
the
uh
kwang liam lay
in after three games but magnus made it
to tiebreak so he gains one extra point
for actually reaching the tiebreaker so
magnus is now the clear leader after day
five alireza catching up to them uh with
11 boys he uh completely demolished han
smoke and niemann uh anish giri with
seven liam le with six duda with six and
eleven arunan who lost to anishigiri uh
yeah with with five points so that's the
game or those were the games those were
the standings hope you guys enjoyed that
uh i would like to thank raymond rafael
buntiak pang amara
and charles bartholomew for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
i'm thankful for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
ftx crypto cup uh until it finishes so
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day